hey
welcome to the monitor hurricane sandy's
come and gone
but with a rescue dog
a cup of cocoa we're gonna see this one
through talking about video games in all
their manifestations we're going to talk
about
the game that really kicks off the
holiday season of big console releases
we're going to talk about the way you're
going to be spending your commute for
the foreseeable future but first we're
going to talk about a movie
predicated on the love of retro video
games and that of course is disney's
wreck-it ralph it is out this weekend
with disney and pixar kind of joining
forces what's nice is that the rising
tide lifts all boats but over the past
decade or so pixar movies have always
been the kind of coin of the realm this
these have been the animated movies that
everybody loves everybody goes sees are
critically acclaimed and make
what is referred to in variety as boffo
box office however
since tangled which came out in 2010
disney has been upping its talent
internally and upping its projects and
wreck-it ralph is really the first of
these to bear fruit rich moore who
directed it is uh is a lover of video
games and that love really shines
through in this tale of a video game
character who doesn't like his job um it
sounds simple but it kind of provides
this great internal conflict that
propels the movie it's got fantastic
voice acting giant c riley sarah
silverman jane lynch which means there's
enough humor and the line readings are
are nuanced enough and and great enough
for for adults kids are going to love
the colors adults are also going to love
the colors adults are going to love the
old school video game references in a
way that kids might not pick up there's
plenty of easter eggs but those video
game easter eggs don't overwhelm the
movie it is at its core just a story of
people but it's overlaid with this
fantastic sense of nostalgia and disney
has some a few really incredible
projects planned in coming years and
their their resurgence kind of begins
now and that's with wreck-it ralph so if
you want to see a hint of what's going
to be coming from the mouse house you're
going to want to see wreck ralph and
even if you don't care you're going to
want to see wreck-it ralph anyway trust
me on this one it's great let's check
that out this weekend but let's talk
about real video games
okay thank you now because the fourth
quarter of the year is upon us the video
game onslaught has begun
the lead up to the holidays means that
all the developers and publishers are
rolling out their really high profile
quote aaa console releases and the first
of the season well if you don't count
borderlands 2 the first of the season
assassins creed three hit stores and
digital download this week it is the
fifth assassin's creed game even though
it is assassin's creed 3 because the
previous two games were kind of
refreshed titles to assassin's creed ii
but being three there is a much needed
total overhaul you are playing a new
assassin in a new time period
specifically the american revolutionary
war and you are going from england to
boston to new york it is it is huge not
only is it as big uh as the renaissance
games assassin street 2 revelations and
brotherhood but it's somehow even bigger
they've taken cues from a lot of other
open world games and they've made this
one really sprawling there's a lot more
stuff you can do
some people are being oddly nitpicky
about this in their reviews but for my
money i'm back on the franchise i've
kind of i've fallen out of love out of
even like
after revelations and brotherhood i felt
like they were just kind of warmed over
rehashes but assassin's creed 3
represents kind of a return to form uh
the same reasons that i really really
fell in love with assassin's creed 2
which was my one of my favorite games of
the past five years and so assassin's
creed 3 is a worthy successor
if you're new to the series it's totally
fine there's kind of a nice orientation
video at the beginning of the game to
get you up to speed
it means you don't have to go back to
assassin's creed 2 to learn the glory of
the franchise so that is out this week
and it is only the first of many huge
releases to come
between now and the end of the year so
if you're feeling killy pick it up
back to you
okay thanks for that
and let's go from big games to little
games specifically letterpress which
came out late last week for ios it's
available for the iphone and ipad it was
developed by a young guy named lauren
brichter who was known or made his bones
or whatever you want to call it
developing the twitter app tweety he's
he's he's turned his attention to word
games which i'm a huge fan of and i am
happy to say that letterpress has joined
the collection on my phone that includes
such standouts as zack gage's spell
tower and welder from iopa games
letterpress is essentially a mashup of
boggle and a terry a territory control
game basically you take turns it's a
two-player game only asynchronous you
take turns forming words on a
boggle-like board except the word the
letters don't have to be next to each
other like they do in boggle so for each
word you make those letters that you
made become yours so there's this uh
there's this element of taking control
of letters and then defending them with
other letters
it's a really minimal interface and it
grabs you fast um it's free to play
but if you want to change the color
themes and play more than one game at a
time it's 99 cents and after i played
one game i immediately upgraded because
this is just how i am with these kinds
of games i have a shameful number of
these games going uh if you're looking
for something a little smaller scale
something that's perfect for a commute
or for downtime coffee break thing like
that it's letterpress definitely
letterpress but that's it for the
monitor this week i'm gonna go catch my
breath i've been speaking for way too
long so on behalf of the sleeping dog
riley and my now lukewarm cup of hot
chocolate i'd like to bid you a due of
course you can always email us at the
monitor at wired.com with criticism
suggestions and
unqualified praise but until next week
when we'll see you back here
inspirational catchphrase here